our favorite ramen loving ninja might
have a happy smile on his face at most
times but it hides a tragic past an
outcast feared by his fellow villagers
for his powers an orphan who loses his
mentor all too soon a young boy
desperate to win friends and acceptance
Naruto's journey to adulthood is a
struggle but rather than be defeated he
dares to hope and dream of being a great
ninja and leading Konoha as its Hokage
one day as Naruto matures from a
troublemaker to a talented ninja who
never loses his compassion and will to
help others numerous tragedies shape his
life truly the series has you running
for the tissue box at the drop of a hat
with its tragic backstories ultimate
tales of sacrifice and the deaths of too
many favorite characters these moments
are as intrinsic to the anime as its
wonderful characters endearing storyline
and brilliant action here come the
waterworks as we take a look at the top
10 saddest moments in Naruto don't say
we didn't warn you
[Music]
on their first big mission outside
Konoha team 7 is up against the dreaded
Zabuza at the end of an epic show of
ninjitsu zabuza's life hangs by a thread
as he faces Kakashi's lightning bolt
suddenly Haku shields his master Zabuza
treated the young orphan he picked up on
his travels as nothing more than a talk
but when Naruto rages at him for showing
no emotion for Haku sacrifice and cries
bitter tears for his enemy even the
unfeeling Zabuza has moved to tears and
force embrace his humanity lying beside
Haku in his dying moments the mercenary
wishes for them to be together till the
very end and there you have it
even the demon of the Hidden Mist is
capable of such raw and honest emotion
each
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if there's anyone who grew up as lonely
as Naruto its Gaara the sand ninja loses
his mother of birth is kept at arm's
length by his father the Kazakh are gay
and is feared by the village like Naruto
he has a beast sealed within him in this
bleak existence Gaara has just one
person he trusts his maternal uncle
Yasha Mora
when the young Gaara fatally injured an
assassin one night he discovers to his
horror that it's none other than his
kind
uncle Yasha Mora tells Gaara his father
sent him and that his mother never loved
him this moment marks gaara's
transformation from an unloved child
into a cold ruthless boy he edges the
word love on his forehead a message to
the world he hates that he'll love only
himself until Naruto melts his icy heart
and saves him
at number 8 we have Nagi sacrificing his
life to save Naruto during the battle
against Madara and obito serious and
cold nay jeez a member of the Hyuga
clans branch family and at first nursed
a deep resentment for the main family
and their Hinata knowing that he could
never lead the clan despite his obvious
talent he's also dismissive of Naruto
calling him a failure for his attitude
changes when the clumsy ninja surprises
him by beating him in the Chunin exams
teaching him a valuable lesson
Neji who always cursed his destiny but
accepted it without question realizes
that one is free to choose one's own
fate it becomes a protective brother to
Hinata an affable partner to his
teammates and one of canoas greatest
talents all these qualities only make
his death more tragic as he shields
Naruto and Hinata from the ten tails
attack as he dies the curse mark on his
forehead borne by members of the branch
family fades to seal his Byakugan
forever and there isn't a dry eye in the
house
don't wipe your tears just yet here
comes another tearjerker threatened by
the akatsuki's rising clouds
Hanzo sets up a trap for its founders
the kidnaps Conan and pushes Nagato to
kill yahiko their leader to save himself
and herb unwilling to let his friend
bear such a burden
yahiko sacrifices himself by walking
into Nagato's knife asking him to
fulfill their dream of bringing peace to
a war-torn world
yahiko selfless death isn't just one of
the saddest moments in Naruto it marks
the drastic change the gentle Nagato
undergoes on his way to becoming one of
the series most conflicted villains he
vows to bring peace by all means even if
it means waging war with the power of
his renege on he creates the six paths
of pain using corpses he controls
remotely including that of yahiko
Nagato leads the Akatsuki from the
shadows making the dead yahiko its face
when his salvation finally comes it's at
the hands of Naruto who resembles yahiko
in so many ways
[Music]
scusi Oh Rhett oh sorry King chicken
salsa
next up we have Obito's death in the
great ninja war as the boy who dreams of
becoming Hokage is unfailingly kind to
the elderly is in love with rain and all
too obviously jealous of the prodigious
Kakashi the young Ichi has pure of heart
and endearing as the playful tobe he
makes us laugh with his antics as the
conflicted point of mother as elaborate
war game he gives the franchise one of
its greatest antagonists and with his
death he redeems himself fatally wounded
Obito's persuaded by naruto to join the
shinobi alliance in its final onslaught
against Kaguya he uses the last reserves
of his chakra to save Kakashi's life a
second time as he fades away
he tells naruto you must become Hokage
this moment counts as one of the saddest
in the anime but also hints at a happy
ending of sorts with a young again Obito
reunited with rin in the afterlife
a mother's undying love is our pick for
the fifth saddest moment in Naruto
having sealed the rampaging nine tails
inside their infant son to save Konoha
Minato and Kristina are on the verge of
death in final message Kristina tells
him not to be a picky eater stay healthy
make friends and live well in true
Kushina style she also warns him of the
three vices women alcohol and money and
the corrupting influence of all Jiraiya
sensei as Kristina gathers all of her
love for her baby into one big goodbye
the moments made all the more
bittersweet by our knowledge of the
lonely life that waits Naruto
[Music]
[Music]
panjabi or middle
on poor nearly panettone America next we
have Naruto's goodbye to Minato time for
another bittersweet farewell it's the
end of the great ninja war and Naruto
has to say goodbye to Minato the father
he just got to know before his
reanimated forms returned to the
afterlife Minato wishes his son a happy
17th birthday complements him on growing
up into a fine young man and promises to
tell his mother
everything about him smiling through his
tears Naruto reassures Minato that he
has been eating well as many friends and
teachers he respects and that he's no
longer lonely when Naruto meets Kushina
spirit from before the war it's a
reunion filled with tears but also
laughter and fond memories but when he
says goodbye to Minato the bright smile
slowly crumbles and he can barely hold
his tears neither can we knowing it's
the last time Naruto will get to see
either of his parents in this lifetime
but we also rejoice that he got the
chance to do so bringing up the top
three is the death of a teacher facing
the ritual obsessed hidan I assume is
tricked into forming a fatal blood bond
with the immortal Akatsuki member as the
sky darkens and rain falls death comes
fast and unexpected in his last words to
Ino Choji and Shikamaru as their sensei
Asuma reminds them of their strengths
and weaknesses and dies after a final
puff of his cigarettes it's always sad
when a prominent characters killed off
and there's plenty of them in Naruto but
are sumers deaths all the more poignant
because of its impact on his students
and his unborn child we can safely say
this is the first time we see any real
emotion from the aloof Shikamaru it's
also the first time we see the level of
his intelligence and foresight as he
plots an ambitious and totally
satisfying end for the unkillable hidan
when his grief finally reaches its limit
he wails inconsolably over an upturned
shogi board a game that will forever
remind him of his gentle and strong
teacher
whether you got me CBL
or my an equator Vicky copypasta
whatever
whatever Oh Maya to tamati to skills
I'll pop a newcomer
akitsuki member Itachi has the dubious
distinction of slaughtering his entire
clan in one night Sasuke the only
surviving og ha has made it his life's
mission to kill his sibling when the
promise fight to the finish happens it's
everything we could have wished for both
skilled fighters the brothers throw
everything they've got at each other and
dance some more but it's the final
moment between them that makes it number
2
Itachi closes in on Sasuke seemingly to
take his eyes to replace his own damaged
pair but instead he falls dead to the
ground after playfully poking Sasuke's
forehead an affectionate gesture he'd
often used in childhood confused by the
outcome Sasuke is thrown into a deep
despair when he finally learns the truth
behind the massacre and Itachi's actions
these moments cement Itachi's position
as the Naruto universe's greatest tragic
hero don't fight me on this one you
quoted si huh
[Music]
- no need oh she show you three - so
Mahima - nah
so darou Naruto yo
browning up the list is another mentors
death Naruto hasn't seen much love and
laughter until Jiraiya comes along
irreplaceable
irresponsible and pervy the
shaggy-haired sage seems like anything
but a good influence in his company
Naruto hones his skills masters sage
jutsu and most importantly controls his
nine tails chakra Jiraiya's a father
figure and the biggest influence in
Naruto's life when the toad sage is
killed by pain during an
intelligence-gathering mission Naruto's
grief knows no bounds while the sight of
Jiraiya being struck down by a beloved
former student is tragic enough it's
heart-wrenching to see Naruto sitting
under the lamp of a convenience store
holding on to a double stick ice
popsicle a treaty used to share with his
mentor the melting ice and Naruto's
flowing tears make for the saddest
moment on this list well that's our list
of the top 10 saddest moments in Naruto
we know you cried buckets comment if you
agree with the list or if you think
we've missed any moments God knows
there's already enough tragedy in Naruto
to last us a lifetime like the video and
subscribe to the channel for more anime
and Naruto content and I'll see you next
time on beanie tube
[Music]
you